l'italie a décidé de produire elle-même
dès le mois de juillet 10 millions de
doses du vaccin rue spoutnik v une
première parmi les 27 pays membres de
l'ue eux alors que les livraisons des
sérums antico vie 19 sont à la traîne
sur le continent européen
tout le monde attend le vaccin avec
impatience mais on n'attend pas des
déclarations on attend le vaccin le
peuple attend les douze concrètes
malheureusement father et astrazeneca et
je ne parle pas ici des producteurs du
vaccin russes ont fait de nombreuses
déclarations promettant que tous les
italiens seraient vaccinés d'ici joie
qu'on prend malheureusement parfaitement
bien que ce ne sera pas le cas c'est que
tant qu'il n'y aura pas de vaccin les
gens souffrir
c'est pourquoi tout le monde attend avec
impatience le vaccin spoutnik v l'italie
n'est pas le seul pays de l'ue à se
montrer impatient face au processus de
bruxelles jugé trop lent la hongrie a
commencé à administrer le vaccin russe à
sa population le mois dernier la
république tchèque et la slovaquie ont
également passé commande à moscou ces
entorses à la politique anti kovy 19
mené par l'union européenne ne sont pas
du goût de charles michel dans le viseur
du président du conseil européen
moscou et pékin ne nous laissons pas
leurrer par la chine et la russie régime
aux valeurs moins enviable que le nôtre
lorsqu elle distille des opérations très
limité mais largement médiatisée sur les
vaccins nous pouvons être impatient pas
aveugle et l'europe n'instrumentalise
pas les vaccins à des fins de propagande
elle promeut des valeurs spoutnik v a
entamé la semaine dernière une étape
déterminante en vue de son déploiement
dans l'union européenne
le sérum russe est actuellement passée
au crible par l' agence européenne des
médicaments basée à amsterdam
en attendant les autorités russes se
sont dit prêtes à fournir des vaccins à
50 millions d'européens
à partir du mois de juin